I have a wonderful electronic invention
I want you to
[Music]
it's exciting for call duty
and then guess what
five seconds five thirty thirty Seconds
call backups large size it's coming
I'm popping everything demanding five
sugars
this is we want to start over medical
books with you Clarence
[Applause]
[Music]
this is doing
[Applause]
we've got out of the reveal event okay
I'm not gonna lie I'm kind of excited
about black ops blackout are you yeah
it's a lot of information to take in it
was so much information in the zombies
there's like so much that's going into
it that it was actually slightly
overwhelming and extremely violent at
one point I was like oh wow you guys
really you really went there yeah they
went for it as a full Centon chair
expired super exciting we were about to
play we're gonna be capturing some
gameplay and thankfully matt is on my
team and not on the other side so
hopefully
I would just get yelled at so they gave
us our USB to record with I got a tmartn
a whole bunch of my YouTube friends oh
I'm just glad that that's on my team
that's right
japanese serif reporting for duty here's
a little bit of gameplay from our
domination games we've played and
spoiler alert we actually ended up
losing this I'm not proud of it either
way we were playing on PlayStation and I
actually play on xbox so that's gonna be
my excuse as to why I'm not playing
perfectly and I didn't do my best and
why we didn't win what's life if he
can't blame somebody else or make an
excuse for why you're not doing
something correct I'd say one of the
biggest takeaways from today's event and
I'm totally okay with this
is that there isn't gonna be a
single-player campaign mode to be
completely honest with you I always
start playing the campaigns and then I'm
like I'm just gonna go back to
multiplayer because that's what I really
enjoy playing they did mention something
about if you do like to play alone
there'll be some sort of solo and p.m.
zombies they didn't really go into
specific details they said this a few
times on different occasions talking
about people with spillovers who does
seem like they are trying to drag this
all asleep towards some new players who
maybe better play the franchise before
which is interesting to think about
because there really are new people
who've never played call of duty maybe
some of you guys out there I have not
ever played the game there is also some
exciting news for color you PC players
the Cole Duty is now coming to battlenet
for the first time which is kind of
Awesome actually they'll have dedicated
servers uncapped framerate and 4k HDR
ultrawide monitor support what almost
makes me want to try it out I don't want
to get into a fight with a PC
master-race but I like my xbox I don't
want to fight with the PlayStation
people either I just want to play games
where I love play games and we left
alone there was also lots of zombies
updates they showed a bunch of different
custom options and modes there was also
like gladiator arena and a Titanic
cruise ship and it was cool but because
they showed like little mini stories
surrounding each of these scenarios but
then everyone eventually turned into
zombies and then that was the end of the
trailer one of the things that was
rumored
they all pretty much assumed that this
was going to happen it almost has to
happen they announced a battle royale
map and it's called blackout you know
much like for tonight and punk G they
didn't see how many players would be
dropped into the maps but what makes it
so interesting is because they have such
a huge IP at the possibilities of
integrating so many past stories
multiplayer maps zombies modes
characters into one huge massive battle
royale map is really really cool haters
are gonna hate but I think this is gonna
be pretty awesome let me know what you
guys think in the comments below about
the game did you watch the reveal if you
didn't you probably should watch it
because I think I did a really bad job
of summing it all up
which guys I'm playing i catched a
little bit of gameplay Matt what did you
think I actually enjoyed it a lot I had
a lot of fun I mean the guns feel
exactly like they do in black ops 3 I
didn't get to use a lot of the
specialist which I think it's going to
change the way that you interact and
move within the map oh and you brought
your own controller I did remind for
Charlie Rhodes I did not bring my own
controller and I play on Xbox as well so
that's a thing oh my goodness and it's
Jordan hello how are you doing I'm doing
great
hi I know I must I missed my time I was
supposed to start at 11 and I think we
at the front they're like you want to
play on PC do you want to play on
PlayStation I was like PC sounds great
I'll head over there well they're only
capturing here so
well you're gonna have something like
game play if you want it's not very good
oh the game is fun my gameplays are not
very good hopefully get to play the
grappling hook though no because Matt
kept taking that specialist like not
more than one person happen nope one
specialist 14 that's why everyone else
on my team was like hey how do I try the
grappling by I'll just selected 2.0 but
this is 3.0 oh yeah happen announces way
better well should be gonna get you know
I took the game was really quite the
fact that you can manually hear yourself
but I like better than all that is the
zombies the new storyline and how cool
looks and the mythical creatures nests
I'm all ready for it I'm excited for the
blackout so it's like you not I'm
excited for it but there's already so
much of that coming out I just like the
whole storyline of zombies and I'm a big
fan of zombies so yeah I don't like
Lee's Ami's that much I'm kind of
excited for the to see what they do at
the battle royale just the fact they're
taking all of like the black ops
characters and franchises and basically
everything in the black ops world and
turning it into one long lab is gonna be
really cool but yeah it's gonna see you
yeah I'm so happy to see you to collab
soon let's do it you have to maven
there's a there's a meme that was lovely
of you with a wig the blonde wig is like
my favorite meme ever just like you know
what do you guys think
[Music]